on va faire le point justement sur les
masques mesure obligatoire sur la
résistance aussi avec le docteur richard
massé c'est le conseiller médical
stratégique et la direction générale de
la santé publique que du ministère de la
santé bonsoir merci d'être avec nous
bonjour bondi tout d'abord vous vous
avez pris aucune résistance il ya un
noyau qui ne veut pas porter le masque
on est conscient qu'il ya des gens qui
voient ça comme un limitations de leur
liberté
ceci dit c'est pour le bien être de tout
le monde c'est toujours un équilibre
délicat entre les libertés individuelles
la protection de l'ensemble de
population on a demandé depuis plusieurs
semaines d'ailleurs que les gens
utilisent le masque dans les endroits
publics et il y en a plusieurs qui l'ont
fait
merci beaucoup mais on voit qu'il ya
encore une résistance et je pense que
c'est nécessaire d'aller plus loin
actuellement parce que des gens qui sont
complètement asymptomatiques qui savent
pas qu'ils sont malades et qui
essentiellement peuvent transmettre dans
cette période l'ovation aucun symptôme
aux autres donc c'est absolument
important de pouvoir protéger les gens
de cette transmission leurs cris 6 pour
ceux qu'on est obligé de le faire
qu'est ce qui peut marcher dans votre
message dans votre communication
exactement en face parce que en italie
progressivement puis on s'est dit on va
dire aux gens qu'ils peuvent utiliser le
masque
on recommande fortement d'utiliser le
masque et on a vu que cette résistance
là elle était présente plus présente
même qu'on aurait pu s'y attendre
et donc là dans certains endroits on est
arrivé à devoir les posies en était et
sans arriver à une solution comme celle
d'orge
mais on voit l'impact si on garde dans
le métro on parle d'à peu près cinq ans
pour ça entre 80 et 90 pour ça c'est
vraiment une grosse différence
est ce que c'est vraiment efficace moi
je reçois le tellement de messages la
part de téléspectateurs qui pose cette
question est ce que des études qui
affirme qu'elle que c'est efficace et
que ça va faire une différence
il ya beaucoup de genres de masse
différencions parle d'un masque
chirurgical ou est ce qu'on appelle
ahmad de procédure mais le ceci couvre
comme étant très efficace si on regarde
découvre visage et beaucoup de sorte de
couvre visage puis des non dits il ya
des gens qui ont des noms identifiés
qu'est ce que c'était la maison et ça
enfants offrent une bonne protection
mais pas une protection aussi grande
mais quand même une protection qui est
plus grave que donne
pour l'amour de l'intérêt qu'on a eue de
dire vos rares des masques accessible à
ceux qu'ils n'ont pas et puis on va dire
aux gens qu'est ce que c'est que ces
masques le poids à vache met
définitivement un niveau de protection
qui est pas 100% mais qui réduit les
risques de transmission et dans notre
situation on pense que ça peut faire une
demi-heure
donc quand vous êtes ça réduit les
risques de transmission en fait on porte
le masque est ce qu'on porte pour se
protéger soi donc on empêche les
gouttelettes de rentrer dans nos voies
respiratoires ou est-ce qu'on pose pour
se protéger pour protéger les autres
finalement pour éviter de répondre nos
propres gouttelettes vers les autres
exactement affectionne les masques c'est
pas des masses qu'on utilise pour se
protéger soi même ça existe ce genre de
masque l'homme et c'est un autre type de
match complètement différent cdma ce qui
protège les autres contre nous delaleux
jusque jeudi le raisonnement de la
protection de la soupe social de ducos
fait un geste pour protéger les autres
pour contre ces infections et
l'efficacité dépend de la qualité du
couvent remise âge que vous allez mettre
que vous avez acheté et puis la façon
que vous le portez parce qu'il ya des
gens qu'ils portent pas bien non plus on
voit des gens qu'ils portent en dessous
du nez il faut un match d'un coup
vraiment en supportant dont on parle on
parle de quelque chose qui couvrent le
nez la bouche et qui est bien adapté oui
on va justement de la façon dont on
porte le masque r on a fait une entrevue
avec docteur françois marquis le de
l'hôpital maisonneuve rosemont
il nous faisait toujours de mise en
garde est dit par exemple un masque vous
ne portez pas deux fois de suite alors
il donne l exemple vous allez au
restaurant vous l'enlever mais après
avoir terminé la consommation du repas
vous ne reperde épaules même la semoy
j'aimerais vous entendre là dessus parce
que tellement de gens qui ont réagi
l'entrevue qui on faisait ça commence à
être un peu compliqué bon en milieu de
soins on réutilise pas les masques ont
calé masques en papier on les utilise
pas en milieu a public des gens qui on
découvre le visage en dessus on peut les
utiliser aussi son soulier s'ils sont
mouillés généralement après une
utilisation de quelques hasard 3,4 à sa
dépend de l'utilisation de la chaleur
ambiante de chuck lorre c'est plus
vraiment utilisable donc si vous le
mettez dans des conditions qui sont pas
des petites pochettes que vous pour
avoir une méthode de taxi et pas
souiller s'est pas mouillé vous pouvez
les utiliser
et si c'en est un
mais c'est un masque et en papier doit
c'est pas la même chose c'est des coups
au visage c'est fait pour un usage mais
les gens s'achètent vous savez quand
vous parlez des masques en papier
j'aimerais qu'on précise les gens ont
besoin vraiment que tout soit concret ça
c'est les petits matchs de procédure le
qu'ils sont blancs d'un côté bleu de
notre côté on peut acheter semaine dans
les quincailleries
il ya des gens qui m'ont un cri qui
existent bien écoutez si je le porte
si je le retire je fais sécher à quelque
part je laisse le quelque part dans ma
maison est bon on dit que le virus ça
peut pas ça finit par mourir sur les
surfaces ils vont peut-être finir par
mourir dans le masque aussi si jamais
j'ai été en contact
est ce que je peux leur apporter
quelques jours plus tard mais vous avez
raison d'être concrète comme ça parce
que quand on met un match comme ça on
dit faut lever entre les deux puis le
masque et qui est en papier on peut pas
la vie c'est ça la différence avoir
qu'un masque en tissu on le lave parce
que ça qu'on dit aux jeunes montés panel
deux ans trois ans 80 points soit vous
la vie mais le masque en attaque ayant
rien à faire avec cela vous devez jeter
à ce moment à l'autre pas voilà donc le
reporter va porter à porter à manille
puis efficace parce qu'il puis est entré
anciennement les microbes peuvent être
des morts
après mes donc deux jours où une journée
complète mais mais il ya ce moment là il
est moins étanche payer
je comprends que quand c'est un papier
quand c'est fait pour être jetables il
faut respecter le mode d'emploi
finalement il faut le jeter
revenant sur les disques en tissu le
réflexe de tout le monde finalement là
on parle sans menace parce qu'on est
dehors une fois qu'on va rentrer dans un
lieu public fermé belle on le prend on
le porte une fois qu on a terminé notre
course
souvent on l'enlève pour le met dans la
poche arrière des shorts ou des
pantalons ou dans le fond de sa bourse
finalement si on va plus tard dans un
autre commerce on l'aurait presque on
peut le manipuler comme ça où vous êtes
le masque même en tissu et pour mettre
dans un petit sachet faut être un petit
peu plus prudent que juste le mettre
dans sa poche arrière même la poche
arrière il s'assoit dessus puis le lait
qui ne savait plus difficile mais moi
j'aime bien dans une poche mais je mets
dans une pochette juste au maire pour le
regarder droit propos qu'ils soient
salle pour qu'il soit attaché de
d'autres choses le fait que c'est jeu
j'aime mieux de mettre dans une pochette
mais à défaut de le mettre dans une
pochette vous mettez dans votre poche
bien qu liés ce qu'il faut c'est pas le
laisser traîner pour que les gens
puissent toucher ou de manipuler ou quoi
que ce soit il sait que son équipage
vous savez on le pli comment en fait on
peut plier en deux et puis loeb pour lui
replié sur lui-même
elle voulait c'est la partie interne du
masque à l'est à l'intérieur donc vous
gardez la partie qui prennent la route à
l'intérieur
bon quand vous avez parlé tantôt des
masques on a tendance à descendre sur le
menton qu'on veut s'exprimer où on a
l'impression que l'on est dans un moment
où on n'est pas à risque
vous vous dites c'est pas une bonne idée
pourquoi c'est pas une bonne idée alors
qu'on a l'impression ce moment-là bon
choix de m pas vraiment dresse pourquoi
je pourrais pas le descend son menton
soymalau vous contaminer tout le visage
avec beaucoup de pression c'est pas
nécessaire mais ce qui est mieux
puis les gens généralement ils pensent
des fois de leur mettre des fois ils le
remettent à moitié des foyers mais de
façon incomplète
une des choses pour ne mentionner au
geste il faut pas jouer avec le masque
il faut pas que le mas qui commencent à
admettre une partie du visage le visage
au complet met nos mains sur nos yeux et
fera donc en quelque part il peut avoir
aussi des sécrétions de dos personnes
sont reçues sur le masque qu'à ce moment
non plus contaminés maintenant il faut
jouer le moins possible oui mais dans
les faits la si on parle des vraies
villes suisses se promener dans les rues
tout le monde a le masque accroché à une
aurait descendu en bas du menton a
glissé au bras n'importe quoi c'est sans
la réalité d'un terme à c est vraiment
le message de communication à faire j'ai
l'impression mais c'est ça ça doit faire
partie la norme sociale
on a appris tout le monde a pris
maintenant j'espère à tousser dans le
coude
et puis à se laver les mains et puis il
y a comme un sas qu'on puisse laver les
mains je pense qu'il faut qu'on apprenne
à porter le masque régulièrement de
façon correcte de la v4 le masque en
tissu et puis de reporter quand les
profits de l'entreposer correctement
aussi jeu mais c'est sur un
apprentissage bonne chose donc
en asie les gens sont habitués utilise
ça depuis des générations mais nous nous
rendons apprendre à l'utiliser et il va
falloir que des campagnes de
communication pour informer les gens
mais tu es déjà eu des outils mais je
pense qu'il faut aller plus loin que les
outils il faut faire des campagnes
d'information docteur masse et merci
beaucoup c'est fort intéressant on
appris plein de choses
ça me fait plaisir bonjour merci bonjour